Pessoal, hoje eu quero conversar com
vocês sobre um assunto que tem chegado
muito no meu consultório ultimamente. É
sobre a síndrome de ativação
mastocitária, armosa S ou siglo inglês
MCAS. E a pergunta que mais escuto é:
doutor, precisa mesmo tomar remédio pro
resto da vida? E olha, imagina, você tá
lá de boa e do nada seu corpo começa a
reagir como se tivesse sendo atacado por
um exército de invasores. Só que pera
aí, não tem invasor nenhum. É tipo
aquele alarme de carro que dispara
sozinho no meio da madrugada, entende?
Pois é, isso é mais ou menos o que
acontece na S. Os mastócos, que são
nossas células de defesa, meio que ficam
pilhadas demais. Eles são como aqueles
seguranças super dedicados que vem
perigo em tudo. Uma mudança de
temperatura, um alimento diferente, até
mesmo o estresse do dia a dia vira
motivo para soltar um monte de estamina
e outras substâncias inflamatórias no
corpo. E é aí que a coisa complica,
porque os sintomas são dos mais
variados. Tem gente que fica com a pele
toda vermelha e coçando. Outros têm
problemas digestórios que parecem não
ter fim. Dor de cabeça que não passa com
nada, cansaço extremo. Alguns pacientes
meus relatam até sensação de desmaio e
palpitações. É um verdadeiro caos
bioquímico.
Agora vamos ao que interessa, a questão
dos medicamentos. Olha, eu vou ser bem
franco com vocês. Na maioria dos casos,
sim, os medicamentos são necessários.
Mas calma, não é para ficar desesperado
ou desesperada.
Deixa explicar melhor.
Os antistamínicos, por exemplo, são como
aqueles bombeiros que chegam para apagar
o incêndio. Eles bloqueiam a ação da
estamina, aquela substância liberada
pelos mastócitos e ajudam a controlar os
sintomas mais chatos. Tem também os
estabilizadores de mastócos, que são
tipo uns calmantes para células
hiperativas. Em casos mais graves, a
gente pode precisar até de epinefrina ou
adrenalina autoinjetável. é aquela
canetinha que salva vidas em caso de
anafilaxia.
Mas aqui é que vem a boa notícia. A
medicina funcional tem mostrado que dá
para fazer muito além de remédios. E é
isso que eu sempre falo pros pacientes.
Remédio é importante, mas não é a única
ferramenta na nossa caixa de
ferramentas. A quecetina, por exemplo, é
um flavonoide poderoso que tá presente
em alimentos, como é o caso da cebola
roxa e da maçã. Estudos recentes mostram
que ela pode ser até mais eficaz que o
cromoglicato de sódio em estabilizar
mastócitos.
A dose geralmente fica entre 500 a 1000
mg por dia, mas sempre use com
acompanhamento, OK? A vitamina C, outra
aliada fundamental, sabe que ela estora
de que a vitamina C é só pra gripe?
Esquece, ela tem um efeito
antihistamínico natural potente. Quando
os níveis de vitamina C caem, a estamina
dispara exponencialmente. Por isso que
eu sempre recomendo doses mais altas, às
vezes até em contextos de endovenoso, em
casos mais complexos. E tem também a
letreolina
prima da quecetina, que alguns estudos
sugerem ser ainda mais potente. Ela tem
propriedades neuroprotetoras incríveis e
ajuda muito nos casos onde tem o brain
fog, aquela névoa mental que deixa a
pessoa meio aérea. Agora vamos falar das
comidas, porque comer é bom demais, mas
para quem tem sangue pode virar um campo
minado. A dieta baixa estamina é
fundamental. Isso significa dar um tempo
em queijos envelhecidos, vinho tinto,
alimentos fermentados, embutidos. Eu
sei, eu sei. Parece que eu tô tirando
tudo que é gostoso da vida, mas olha,
não é para sempre. É uma fase de
ressetar o sistema e tem muita coisa boa
que pode comer. Alimentos frescos
preparados na hora, carnes frescas,
vegetais como brócolis, escova e flor e
cenoura. O segredo é evitar alimentos
que ficaram muito tempo armazenados ou
processados. E o estresse. Ah, esse é um
grande vilão silencioso. O cortisol
elevado pode disparar os mastócios numa
velocidade impressionante. Por isso que
técnicas de manejo do estresse não são
frescura, são tratamento, meditação,
yoga, respiração profunda, caminhadas na
natureza. Cada um encontra o que
funciona melhor. Eu tive uma paciente, a
dona Maria, que chegou no consultório
tomando cinco medicamentos diferentes
para o S. ainda assim vivia em crise.
Começamos um protocolo integrativo,
mantivemos os remédios essenciais, mas
adicionamos quercetina, vitamina C,
ajustamos a dieta e ela começou a fazer
meditação mindfulness. Em 3s meses
conseguimos reduzir para apenas dois
medicamentos e as crises diminuíram 80%.
O sono também é crucial. Durante o sono
profundo, o corpo regula a produção de
mediadores inflamatórios e dormir mal é
como jogar a gasolina no fogo da
inflamação. Por isso, higiene do sono
não é luxo, é necessidade. E sabe o que
mais? O intestino tem um papel
fundamental nisso também. Grande parte
do mastócio do corpo tá no trato
digestório, gastrointestinal. Quando a
gente tem disbiose ou permeabilidade
intestinal aumentada, é como se deixasse
a porta aberta pros problemas. Por isso
que os probióticos específicos, o
tratamento do intestino são parte sim
essencial do protocolo. Mas doutor,
então dá para ficar sem remédio? Olha,
em casos muito leves, com sintomas bem
controlados e gatilhos bem
identificados, algumas pessoas conseguem
manejar só com as mudanças, estilo de
vida e suplementação natural, mas
exceção, infelizmente, não é regra. A
verdade é que a Sã é uma condição muito
complexa, muito difícil de lidar, é
muito individual. Cada pessoa tem os
seus gatilhos, sua intensidade de
sintomas, sua resposta ao tratamento. O
que funciona para um pode não funcionar
pro outro. Por isso que o acompanhamento
médico é muito importante e médicos
pacientes e que têm experiência nessa
condição para ajustar o tratamento
conforme a necessidade. O que eu sempre
digo é: use o mínimo de medicação
necessária, mas use toda a medicação que
for necessária.
Não adianta querer ser natural, natureba
e viver em sofrimento. Nesse caso, a
gente não pensa só nisso. O objetivo é
qualidade de vida. E tem mais uma coisa
importante, o tratamento da SAM é
dinâmico, conforme vai se equilibrando,
muitas vezes conseguimos reduzir as
medicações, mas isso tem que ser feito
com muito cuidado, muito paciência e com
acomento constante. Roma não foi
construída em um dia e a estabilização
dos mastósos também não acontece da
noite pro dia. Então, respondendo a
pergunta inicial, sim, na maioria dos
casos medicamentos são necessários,
infelizmente, pelo menos no começo, mas
isso não quer dizer, não significa que
você vai ser refém deles pra vida toda.
Com uma abordagem integrativa focando em
nutrição, suplementação estratégica,
manejo do estresse e mudança estilo de
vida, muitos pacientes conseguem reduzir
de forma significativa a necessidade de
medicamentos. O importante é não ter
medo do tratamento, seja com
medicamentos, seja com abordagens
naturais. Objetivo é um só, devolver a
você o controle sobre sua saúde, sobre
sua vida. E acredite, com dedicação e
tratamento correto. É totalmente
possível ver bem com S. Lembre-se, cada
jornada é única. O que importa é dar o
primeiro passo e não desistir. Seu corpo
tem uma capacidade incrível de se
equilibrar quando damos as condições e
ferramentas corretas para ele. E às
vezes essas ferramentas incluem sim os
medicamentos e tá tudo bem com isso. A
medicina funcional nos ensina a olhar o
corpo como um todo, não como partes
separadas. E no caso da Sã, isso faz
toda a diferença. Não é só tomar um
remédio pronto, é entender seus
gatilhos, cuidar do intestino, nutrir o
corpo de forma adequada, gerenciar o
estresse do MIBEM, é um conjunto de
ações que juntas criam o ambiente
prefeito para recuperação. Então é isso,
pessoal. A Sã é desafiadora, sim, com
certeza. Mas é controlável também? É
controlável sim, com abordagem certa,
combinando o melhor da medicina
convencional com as práticas funcionais,
você pode sim ter uma vida plena e
saudável. E lembre-se sempre, você não
estar sozinho ou sozinha nessa jornada.
Ah.